remember so stationary rigid BIOS
shooting at this kilometers houses over
sometimes I think I shot and then that
scene all hell broke loose and this is
the same type of guy who killed his son
yes and have the same gut
fire the same bullets loaded up pull the
trigger point you shoot slides forward
technically you could put 30 rounds in
there in this passage you can pull the
trigger that's up fast 30 rounds would
come out where will you when you find
out it's about 5:00 in the morning I got
a phone call the only reason I ever left
my ringer on my phone was in case
something happened to Jake his mom calls
me around by something the morning and
she says there's been an accident and
immediately I go he just when you have
kids you just stop we have breaking news
this morning a deadly shooting rampage
last July in the small community of
Mukilteo Washington a 19 year old opened
fire on a house party filled with peers
from his high school class this is from
the funeral this is a picture I took of
his last in your game Dave Snider
stepson Jake long a college freshman was
killed in the attack the shooting is a
window into America's obsession with the
ar-15 a rifle increasingly popularized
by movies and videogames that has also
become a weapon of choice for some of
America's bloodiest mass shootings what
happened from what I was told so there
about 20 kids will and Jordan were
outside by an outside kitchen island
with an outside upright fireplace Jake
went over to the corner of the house
this is where the gunman was hiding
apparently looking through into the big
picture windows and looking at his
ex-girlfriend Anna Jake he may have been
going home or whatever happened he
startled the guy and the guy opened fire
on him Jake was shot three times in the
back
Paul Kramer's son will was shot during
the attack but survived all said his son
still wasn't ready to speak with the
press
he took a tough blow a couple months ago
I said let's go and what happened we'll
to look over his shoulder to see he saw
Jake his friend go down and then he got
hit his friend Jordan Abner ran toward
the house to try to get away and the
shooter put six bullets in him
will is laying down and he's hearing the
shooting and the screaming he calls 911
I need ambulances he's laying out in the
yard he's bleeding sugar goes into the
house and goes after his main target his
ex-girlfriend who didn't want to get
back together with him he just stood
above her and put five bullets in there
shooting at this so I'm at this house
and all of our friends that they got
shot so a gadget I don't know where by
the water with her local does the
shooter murdered his ex-girlfriend
Anna Bowie and two other former high
school classmates including Dave stepson
Jake long assault weapons and large
capacity magazines were banned for a
decade during the ban the number of
people killed and wounded with assault
weapons or guns using high-capacity
magazines was cut in half after the ban
expired casualty is shot up by more than
300% and since then ar-15s have been
used in some of America's most notorious
deadliest mass shootings these are good
kids from good loving families as media
attention grew following the shooting
Paul became outspoken about access to
guns like the ar-15 I don't like to see
my fellow citizens killing each other
hearing from a will father a week after
the shooting Paul stood with Washington
attorney general Bob Ferguson at a press
conference as he called on the state
legislature to pass the law banning AR
teen style rifles and high-capacity
magazines yeah I thought about it a
little bit so I said yes I think that's
a good idea to ban those weapons Dave
however disagreed with the call for an
assault weapons ban
he felt that exercising his right to
bear arms was more important than ever
so what was your reaction when he heard
that people wanted to ban assault
weapons partly because of what happened
right away irritation I'm just like man
any reason they can to get their agenda
to go this I kind of felt exploited a
little bit like they're using my
stepsons death to get your own agenda
going on and that just kind of pissed me
off it still does I'm just nothing I can
do about it
Dave had actually just purchased an
ar-15 from the same gun store as the
shooter you bought an ar-15 just a
couple weeks before Jake was killed a
month I'd say what it was a week after
the Florida shooting I remember I even
sent him a picture I'd Jake look at my
new toy got a picture of it and shoot
like shooting down not posing in front
of a mirror or anything but he said
something like cool you know and then he
ends up get killed by Dave then showed
us the ar-15 he purchased it was the
first time he'd taken the gun out of the
case since Jake was killed he's having
this particular gun and makes me feel
safer in the home it does even though
that the fact of the matter is I
wouldn't be able to get this out of all
this wherever locked up get it out fast
enough if I use my hand guns for that
are you prepared to kill someone oh yeah
I would have done that one of 17 when I
was in the military that's what I told
them I do I definitely when it comes to
defending myself or my family
I'll take somebody else problem that
what was your reaction when you first
learned if this
I've gone to kill Jake I don't know and
have a gut distel reaction I don't think
these kind of that whole thing is kind
of Numb shit some people go into anger I
guess I just kind of went dumb I'm kind
of still aluminum
in January Washington attorney general
Bob Ferguson proposed a ban on assault
weapons and magazines that hold more
than 10 bullets do you think that there
is any legitimate reason for owning an
ar-15 I think I've reached the
conclusion that for personal safety for
hunting for the types of uses for guns
that we support as a society answer you
know that's a weapon that does not have
the type of personal use for safety or
for hunting that we feel as a society is
appropriate and relative to cost that we
are seeing in our society on a literally
daily basis the legal definition of an
assault weapon generally includes one or
more of the following features
semi-automatic firing accepts large
capacity magazines pistol grip and
folding stock
[Music]
the shooting was a horrific moment for
the sleepy community of Mukilteo and it
was up to the town's mayor
Jennifer Gregerson to help the community
cope my sense is that the community
feels like yeah that kind of assault
rifle that number of rounds in a
magazine is is one line to draw for our
for our country I don't know when I mean
it's not now when I don't know you
believe that it will make a difference I
believe it would have prevented this
event an effort to create a new federal
assault weapons ban was introduced after
twenty children and six adults were
killed by a gunman with an ar-15 at
Sandy Hook elementary school in 2012 but
the bill was quickly defeated the NRA's
campaign to stop the gun ban pushed
sales of the ar-15 higher and works the
shift to blame of unprecedented violence
to a different industry there exists in
this country sadly a callous corrupt and
corrupting shadow industry it sells and
Stowe's violence against its own people
through vicious violent video games to
better understand the NRA's case against
violent video games I met up with
Christian Allen who is not only an avid
gun collector he's also a leading video
game designer specializing and
first-person shooter games like Halo
there's no statistical causation and all
the studies that have been done between
violent video games and people actually
committing violence in your experience
how many people get their first
introduction to shooting real guns from
video games oh I think a lot of people
have especially these days and you know
I've seen people that got into it
interested in in firearms themselves by
you know playing a game and saying oh
that's my favorite gun you know in the
game and you know I want to get one and
realize before I lay these down I'm just
going to double check them Christian
told me the Attorney General's proposed
assault weapons ban won't work because
unforeseen by lawmakers rules can easily
be sidestepped
this is your classic ar-15 this is a
Ruger mini-14 there's functional
differences but from barrel lengths
magazine capacity bullet cartridge that
uses they're exactly the same the real
difference is aesthetic it's how they
look and if I took this one
they make black folding stock so it
looked just like this and I can make it
all black and people would think it was
an ar-15 over the past decade the ar-15
has become one of the best selling guns
in America the National Shooting Sports
Foundation estimates that Americans
currently owned between five and 10
million ar-15s what changed from getting
that the handguns that the guy at the
shop told you would stop a burglar -
these days people buying this they're
very modular they're inexpensive they're
easy to learn to shoot you know one of
the rules with handguns is that you need
to shoot a lot with handguns to learn
how to shoot them and if you don't not
really no I mean it's it's a pretty
basic once you know the functionality
notes are really powerful at the same
time
pretty
the ar-15 is manufactured by dozens of
American companies including Smith &
Wesson Remington Arms and Ruger if you
look at the advertising for gun
manufacturers you'll see things like at
your man card back and you'll see a lot
of pictures of guys in you know full
tactical gear and we're all dressed up
in there you know super camo and stuff
like that and there's just a segment of
the population that has this idea that
they can be soldiers and some people
take it really seriously well they are
cool to have they know they look cool
you look on YouTube and there's all
these videos people spent thousands on
making theirs look really cool those are
that cool feeling about shotguns not so
cool not so macho you know a lot of that
everybody goes for this alright the
shooter had no gun training but two days
before the shooting he began hinting at
his plans on social media he posted a
photo to Instagram of his newly
purchased Ruger ar-15 and he tweeted
what's Ruger going to think he spent
time in his car reading the owner's
manual that night he read the
instruction manual in the car yes as I
understand it he'd he'd been playing
video games what role do you think that
video games and movies play and
popularizing the ARP well I think it's
just that that's the weapon that people
see a lot and then they want to go buy a
rifle and they go to the store and they
look at a wall full rifles and they see
the one that they know you know it's
Miller on one woody reporting we're
trapped in the bathroom we lost the
doors okay do we know what kind of a gun
he was armed with yeah there's a good
big assault rifle looking how I don't
know I'm guessing from the game girl we
try to make it feel as realistic as
possible
all the audio gunshots in the game were
recorded from real guns I have some land
out east and then I went out with an
audio crew over the weekend and we shot
you know tons of different rifles when
you're in that first-person view
you just feel connected to the character
you might feel like you are the
character
after Jake was killed was there any part
of you that thought about getting rid of
the air no absolutely not
I do have video games I play that have
realistic gun sounds and I cut I cut my
time down and it's kind of hard to play
that game right now because they're very
realistic you hear there's an audio of
the gunshots that happened at the party
that was really unnerving the shooter
had gone upstairs out to like a second
floor balcony area and fired at two of
the young adults who were there trying
to get away okay Natalie is still there
yeah it's not anybody they're on they're
coming they're coming
is there anybody there that saw the
suspect he had another magazine in the
car he left the house went to his car
and drove away
and kept driving he got onto i-5 south
heading towards Portland
[Music]
walk it backwards
the shooter later told police that he
bought an ar-15 because it's quote a
symbol of power here's a 19 year old
young man with his whole life ahead of
him from outward appearances there was
potential there
the shooter pleaded guilty sparing the
families and victims a lengthy trial and
likely sparing himself from Washington's
death penalty in the climate that we
have today where 30 years ago one of
these guys might have gone out taking
his own life today they go out and shoot
someplace up
how do you prevent the kind of thing
from happening again
that happens you don't it'll happen
again
it'll probably happen next week it
happens all around the country all
around the world you can't prevent it I
think they're over 300 million guns in
the United States it's not something
that's being prevented but when we make
it so easy when access to these kinds of
weapons when we make those so easily
accessible it's almost like we're asking
for it
our full documentary series takes on the
issues like the influence of the NRA
smart gun technology and guns on campus
make sure to watch our entire series and
subscribe to aj+
for more docs